لدينا واحدة كبيرة جدا
اختيار
كلنا لا نعرف ذلك مع اللاعبين الذين
يمكنهم إحداث فرق في أي وقت
لكنني أعتقد أنه مع ذلك لن يكون الأمر كذلك
يكفي ليس علينا أن نكون
دفاعيًا عنيفًا ل
بشكل عدواني ، جيدًا ، لتكون قادرًا على وضع علامة على
ثم الاختلاف
حسنًا ، يُقال أنه يمكننا أن نكون أحد
المفضلة لنا
نحن نعرف ما هي نقاطنا
قوي ومعه سنذهب إلى
ثم الفريق الاسباني
أيضا ليس جيدا تقول هذا
الأرجنتين البرازيل وفرنسا على ما أعتقد
قد تكون إسبانيا هناك أيضًا بين
بعض الأشياء المفضلة أعتقد أنهم يفعلونها
عمل ممتاز مع لاعبين جيدين جدا
شابة وجيدة
لويس إنريكي يقوم بعمل
استثنائية أعتقد أن الاختيار
يمكن أن تكون الإسبانية أيضًا مرشحًا
من المفضلة وانظر كيف
سنرى كيف يتطور
خلال كأس العالم